SPEAKER 1: There are a lot
of fantastic UI and component
libraries out there
that work with Angular.
And we are dedicated
to supporting them.
But at the same time, Google
has a design philosophy
called Material Design.
And it was our goal to
encapsulate the best practices
from Material Design and
make it easy for developers
to take advantage
of those things.
And to help demonstrate
and show some
of the capabilities of Material
Design and the Material Design
components, I'd like to
invite Kara Erickson up
to the stage from
the Angular team.
[APPLAUSE]
KARA ERICKSON:
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
OK, so this is going to be
kind of a lightning demo
just to give you a
taste of what it's
like to develop with Angular
and Angular Material.
But all of the code will be
available online on GitHub
after the demo on my
GitHub profile Kara--
so GitHub.com/kara.
OK, so since we use
the Angular CLI,
we can go ahead and
serve right off the bat.
And it will spin up a
local server for us.
So let's just go ahead and
wait for that to spin up.
And on localhost 4200,
we'll see boilerplate text
that comes with the CLI.
All right, so now that we have
everything kind of set up,
let's talk about the
application that we'll actually
be building.
So it's a dating site for
dogs, as we mentioned.
And so let's start by building
the application scaffold.
So we'll need a toolbar at the
top that says the application
name, navigation
menu on the left that
can have our navigation
links for the site,
and most importantly,
the dog profiles.
That will be in the middle so
your dog can find their desired
dog.
So, let's put this over here.
We're going be using Angular
Material to set this up.
So let's start by setting
Angular Material up.
When you use the CLI, it
generates a module definition
file for you.
So these modules kind of come
with it, these three modules.
You'll also need to
import the Material module
if you want to use Material.
Let me make sure
that imported-- yeah.
And then call for a
root on it to make sure
that it comes with all the
providers that it needs.
Next we need to add in the core
styles for Angular Material.
So in our styles.css file,
which was also generated,
we can go ahead and add
Angular Materials core styles
from its npm package.
And we chose the core styles
that are prebuilt with a theme
here.
So you can see it's indigo pink.
And we want to import
the Material Design font.
This will allow us to
add Material Design
icons in a simple way.
So normally we would just
include the link here.
But since we have low
network connectivity,
let's do it offline.
So instead we're just going
to copy-paste the actual style
sheet that we would
have loaded over HTTP.
So now that we are
all done with setup,
we can go ahead and
start changing the markup
for our app component,
so our main component.
So let's start by
building a toolbar.
And we can use the
Material Design
component called mdToolbar.
And we're setting
the color to primary,
which just means that
it's going to take
the primary color from the
palette that we selected,
so indigo, and put that into
the background of our toolbar.
So let's wait for
this to refresh.
You see we have this
nice puppy love toolbar.
So next let's go
ahead and build out
the sidenav menu on the left.
So if you want to
open a sidenav,
you probably need a
menu icon to let people
know that they can click on it.
So we have this lovely
component called mdIcon.
And this allows you to use
the code for a specific icon,
and it will use the font that
we loaded before to turn it
into the actual icon.
So you can see
that with that line
we already have menu
items right there.
You'll also notice that
there's no margin here.
And that's because we don't have
margins for any of our Material
Design components.
And this is by design
because we know
they will depend on
where you're actually
going to be dropping it.
So we let you set your
own margins yourself.
So here we're setting
a custom margin
for the icon and toolbar.
Looks a little bit better.
Next, let's make
this into a button
so that we can open
up the sidenav.
So, we're just going to wrap
the icon in button tags.
And it's going to give it
the default button style.
So we're also going to
tag it with mdIcon button,
so that we get
overrides with those.
So now we need the
actual sidenav.
So we have a component
called mdSidenav.
So if we create
a sidenav layout,
and we put all of our
existing HTML in there,
we go ahead and create the
sidenav with the sidenav tag.
I'm just going to put some
boilerplate in there for now.
And so we can use
this cool trick.
So if we create a local template
variable called sidenav,
when you click on the button
it can call sidenav.open.
So all that means is when
you use the hash syntax,
it's going to set
the sidenav variable
to the sidenav directive.
And then on click, it's
going to call the open method
on that sidenav directive.
So if we click on it, you can
see that we have the sidenav,
but it's not full screen.
So let's go ahead and
add the full screen.
That should be here.
Let that refresh.
All right, so now
we have our sidenav.
So that's cool.
But obviously we don't want
this to be our content, right?
We want a list of
navigation links.
So we have a component for
that called mdSidenavList--
or mdNavList, excuse me.
And navlist takes
a list of anchors.
So we can just add
an anchor here.
And each anchor is
going to be a list item.
So we're going two list items,
one for your account page
and one for your dog profiles.
So each list item is going
to have two lines, one
with the name of the link.
So in this case it's going to
be your account, so [CHINESE].
And then we also want
a description here.
And so we're just
going to see [CHINESE].
So for our second list item, we
want our dog profiles, right?
So we're just going
to say [CHINESE].
And then here we're going
to have a call to action,
so we're going to say [CHINESE].
All right, so let's add
that description class
that we started.
So we're just going to
give it a separate color
for some contrast.
Wait for that to refresh.
So now we have our two links,
which hopefully you can see.
I think it's a little cut off.
So let's add some icons to
the left of each of the link
so you can see visually
kind of what each link is
going to represent.
So this is another thing
that you can do really easily
with the navlist.
So we can use mdIcon once again.
And for a little
account icon, we
can use the assignment end icon.
And we're also going to
tag it with mdList icon
so it's spaced appropriately
for that context.
And then here, we
want a little pawprint
so that we can see
that it's dogs.
So we're just going
to use the pets icon.
All right, cool.
So we basically have our
application scaffold done.
We have our toolbar.
We have a sidenav that
opens with our links.
But obviously we're missing all
the important parts, content.
So let's start by
building our dog profiles.
So we can create
a container here.
And each dog profile is
going to be an mdCards.
That's just like a little
container for information.
And we're going to have a card
for each dog in our dogs array.
So we're going to have to create
that dogs array in a moment.
And then each
card, for now we're
just going to interpolate the
dog's name-- oops, dog.name.
And now we need to
create this dogs array.
So in our component definition,
I've preloaded this dogs array.
And it's just a list of
Angular team dog names.
And the locations
of all of their dog
pictures I already
pasted in here.
And then in our
CSS, you'll recall
that everything needs a margin.
So I'm going to add
margins for the card.
I'm going to give it a width.
And then to ensure that
the cards are organized
in a nice way, I'm just going
to make its container a flex
container.
So let's wait for that
to refresh, because none
of the CSS is there.
OK, there we go.
All right, so now we
have all the dog cards.
So that's cool.
But you can't really tell
much about these dogs.
Let's add a description
for each dog.
So cards also have a
feature for card content.
So we can add a card
content container here.
And we're also going to
give it a description
class for contrast.
And we're just going to
do a generic description
for all of these because
we don't have time
to personalize it.
OK, so we're going
to say [CHINESE].
And we're going to interpolate
once again the dog's name.
And then [CHINESE].
It seems like dog stuff, right?
OK, [CHINESE].
So wait for that to refresh.
OK, cool, and you'll notice
that each of the dogs
has their name
interpolated, too.
So what's a profile without an
image for your dog to examine?
So we can easily
add images to these.
So I'm just going
to get out of this.
So, we'll add an image tag.
We'll tag it with mdCardImage.
That just lets the card know
to make it kind of full width.
And then we're going to take the
source from our Assets folder,
using the dog.image
thing in our array.
And then our alt
text is just going
to be the dog's name, [CHINESE].
So hopefully the
image will show up.
OK, nice, now we have
these lovely dogs.
So next let's create
a way for your dog
to interact with all
of these handsome dogs.
So we can create a
card action section--
card actions section.
And we're going to
align it on the end.
That just puts the
buttons on the right side.
And we're going to
create two buttons.
And they're going to be
style with mdButtons,
make them look a little
nicer, with the primary color
of your palette, which
is once again indigo.
So we want your dog to be
able to sniff the other dog.
This is going to be--
oops, can't type right now.
One second, I think it's frozen.
All right, let me just--
I may have to restart WebStorm.
Hold on.
There we go.
All right, let's reopen this.
Hope that I can type again.
Still can't type.
Come on.
This is not good.
OK, I may have to
restart this computer.
I feel like this is not working.
OK, let's go ahead
and quit WebStorm.
I'm going to try one more thing.
All right, let's restart this.
Please let me type.
I think I may just have
to restart my computer.
Maybe I could try--
let's open [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, nothing's working.
OK, I'm going to restart.
Yeah, why doesn't
Steven do the slides
while I see if I can
get my computer to work?
OK, one second.
SPEAKER 1: That never
happens to any of us,
does it, where
IDE stops working?
So was anyone
impressed with Kara?
That was pretty awesome, right?
[APPLAUSE]
So hopefully it's
making sense how easy
it is to start using some of
these things like the Material
Design components
that we're providing
for you, to make it easy
to build applications
with Angular.
But one of the things
that-- once we've
made it easy to build
applications that we really
care about, is performance,
because performance
is one of the things that
matters more for our users
than for us as developers,
because we tend
to have very powerful
machines, and our users tend
to use mobile devices and
very underpowered machines.
But how do we think
about performance?
So we actually have
a few different ways
of looking at this.
The first is size.
How do we make smaller
bundles, and how do we
use lazy loading to load
them as late as possible?
And then on the
speed side of things,
how do we execute
our programs faster?
How do we do less,
so run less code?
How do we reduce
the amount of memory
we take advantage of, and more.
So when we look back at the
Angular 1.x way of thinking,
we would take your HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript,
and we would actually
have a template compiler.
Most people didn't know
about this template compiler
because it didn't have
much functionality.
At some level we
relied on the browser,
because we were not
DOM independent.
And so we would say,
element.innerHTML,
and we would pass
it a set of HTML
to render it out to the user.
And then you would end up
adding on top of that change
detection, and then
it would all make it
out to the renderer
in combination
with kind of multiple run
times for dependency injection,
change detection, and processing
the view and all those events
that you would set
up by your template.
But if we look at how
Angular 2 is different,
we've pulled the compiler
out as a separate component.
And what that allows
us to do is we actually
generate views from that.
And then those views contain
all of the necessary change
detection code or any of the
event hooks or property hooks.
And so the default mode
for Angular developers
today is what we call
just in time compilation,
where we ship the compiler
down to the browser,
and then in real time,
on the user's device,
we compile all of those HTML,
JavaScript, and CSS files
into JavaScript.
So what happens is you write
NG4 or you write a div tag,
and that ends up becoming
a document.create element
in the most VM optimized way
that we've found ways to.
And so when we do this
sort of compilation,
we're doing it in a
way that's optimized
for all of the JavaScript
virtual machines,
because they all
work very similarly.
But then it's also a
massive improvement
to change detection,
up to 10 times faster.
One of the ways that
we measure performance
is we have what we call
a deep tree benchmark.
So you've got a large tree
with a lot of nodes on it.
And so we built a version
of this application
using pure JavaScript.
And we call that
1.x performance.
And then we went back and
built the same application
using Angular 1, and it
took about 5.7 times as long
to run the change section
and to run this application.
And then we built the same
application in Angular 2,
and it takes 1.5 times as
long as that hand-optimized
JavaScript, without any sort of
optimization in the Angular 2
world.
Another thing that we
can do to take this even
further is what we call
ahead of time compilation.
So because the compiler is
now an independent component,
you can actually do
all of the compilation
at build time instead
of at runtime.
And this is a very
powerful thing
because when you look at
the bundle size of Angular,
around 50% to 80% of
your bundle is actually
the Angular compiler.
And so by not shipping that
down to the browser and only
shipping down that
optimized JavaScript
and removing all of
the compilation steps
from the user, you can get
huge performance increases.
So in AOT it's still
optimized JavaScript
for virtual machines, but
you're not relying on your users
to do that compilation.
And then you get to ship
less code because of it.
And so from a load
time standpoint,
when you compare just in
time compilation to ahead
of time compilation, it
was about 335 milliseconds
in just in time.
It was down to 130.
And we're seeing very similar
gains in terms of size,
getting down to 49
kB in ahead of time
a compilation for our benchmark.
But, what does this actually
mean in the real world?
So there's a company
called Lucidchart who
builds diagramming software.
And when they did the same just
in time compilation to ahead
of time compilation, they
were able to eliminate
the entire middle
part of the graph.
So this is a flame chart from
the Chrome DevTools showing
the processing that was
going on in the browser.
And so by eliminating all
of that middle portion,
the template compilation, the
user's time to interactivity
was much lower.
And so they were benchmarking
against their legacy editor.
And when they added ahead
of time compilation,
they almost always got
ahead of the legacy editor.
But then when they combined the
ahead of time compilation with
something called
Closure Compiler--
and that's optimization
that comes from Closure--
they were able to get
always consistently better
than their legacy editor.
And then they were also able
to get a bundle size down
to about 27 kB for a small
Hello World application.
Another way that we're
increasing performance
is by lazy loading
components and modules
for you using our router.
Routers form a very
natural separation point
between different parts
of your application.
And so using the CLI and
using a webpack plugin
that we've built,
we can actually
code split for you
and only load routes,
and the modules that
represent those routes, when
the user navigates
to them, meaning
huge increases in performance
by pulling things out
of the critical
path for the user.
We also allow you to take
control of change detection
by leaving it always on,
which is the default.
Or you can specify that you only
want to run the change section
cycle on push when the
user's ready to do so.
Or you can even detach entire
components or component trees
from that change
detection process.
And there's a number
of other things
that we're doing to make Angular
much, much more performant.
You can run 80% of Angular in a
web worker, which takes it off
of the UI thread.
So most JavaScript
is traditionally
run on the UI thread, in
a single threaded manner.
And this allows you to
access multithreading
You can run it in
a service worker
and do offline, which
means the user doesn't
have to wait for a network round
trip to load your application.
And we're working to get
faster than that baseline
that we mentioned.
And we're also working to
get the bundle size down
to about 10k.
And our director says that
if we get to about 10k,
he will bake us a cake.
So we're very motivated.
Currently, web workers and
service workers are available.
But we call them experimental.
And we're still
working to get faster
than that hand-optimized
JavaScript in that 10 kB Hello
World.
Unlike Angular 1 where
documentation came much later
than the project, we
wanted to launch Angular 2
with documentation day one.
And we're very proud to have
our own Angular.cn domain
name where we can
host and connect
with the Chinese
community better.
Lastly, community is very,
very important to us.
And so on GitHub, we were
one of the top projects,
by contributor numbers.
And currently as
of October, we had
about 1.2 million
developers looking
at Angular 1 documentation.
And we had about
600,000 developers
looking at Angular
2 documentation,
even only a month
after our release.
So we're experiencing
rapid growth
and we're very
excited about this.
And we're going to continue
to invest in Angular 1
until these graphs switch, until
the majority of the developers
that we work with have
migrated to Angular 2.
We're also very reliant on
a huge ecosystem of partners
who train, who teach, and who
build components and libraries
that are part of our ecosystem.
So we're hugely thankful to
all these people, as well as
the GDGs locally here in China,
as well as Google Developer
Experts, which is a
program we're looking
to expand across the globe.
And then there's also a number
of different applications
that are already
in production using
Angular 2, such as Greentea,
which is a CRM within Google,
Google Fiber, Azure
Functions for Microsoft,
and companies like Capital
One and Fidelity Investments.
So with that, Kara,
would like to continue?
KARA ERICKSON: [INAUDIBLE].
because his Chinese
is better than yours.
SPEAKER 3: I will ask them
if they have any questions.
KARA ERICKSON: No, no, ask them
if they want to see your demo.
SPEAKER 3: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[APPLAUSE]
KARA ERICKSON: Just go.
Let's just go.
Do it.
All right, so I can type again,
something to be happy about.
So where we were, just
to remind you guys,
is we were thinking about action
buttons for our dogs to use.
So the first one was for
your dog to sniff other dogs.
So we wanted to say, [CHINESE].
And then second one was for
your dog to bark at another dog.
So we're going to say [CHINESE].
And we're also going
to make these buttons
just slightly bigger so
you can see them on stage.
So very quickly, I'm going to
make the font size 20 pixels.
Then we're going wait
for this to refresh.
See, they're a little bit
small [INAUDIBLE] right now.
OK, cool.
All right, so now that we
have our action buttons,
we have our dog
profiles, let's start
playing with some of the
other APIs that we have,
like forms and animations.
So it would be really cool if
you could click on a dog name
and it will turn into a text
field so you can edit it.
So we're going to hook
that up right now.
So if we go back to
the dog's title here,
we can wrap that in a span.
Oops, we want to close the tag.
And when you click
this span, we want
to put the dog into edit mode.
And we only want to
show the dog title
if the dog is not in edit mode.
And now we want to
add our text field.
So we can use something
called mdInput for this.
And we only want to show it
if the dog is in edit mode.
And when we blur the input,
we can set edit mode to false.
And then in our
CSS, we want to make
the transition pretty seamless.
So we're going to make the font
size the same for the input.
And we're going to
make its width 100%.
And then since we're not
having a placeholder,
we can set the margin
to zero on the wrapper
so that it is the same height.
And then lastly, since we're
overriding some core styles,
we need to turn off
view encapsulation.
It's there to help
you in case you
have unintended side effects.
But in this case,
we're intentionally
overriding something, so
we want to turn it off.
So wait for that to refresh.
All right, so now when
you click on the name,
it becomes a text field
you can type into.
Obviously we haven't put the
form component in here yet.
So if you remember in
Angular 1, there was ngModel.
In Angular 2 we
also have ngModel.
So if we use the
two-way binding syntax,
we can just put
in dog.name here.
And then as soon
as that refreshes,
when we click on the name
it should prepopulate it.
And it should be able to--
you can see it filling
in on the bottom
there because it's
updating in real time.
So you can say Porter's
Magnificence, et cetera,
et cetera.
So that's a taste of forms.
We don't have time to
do much more than that.
We can also do a very
quick animations demo
to make the cards fade in.
It should only take a minute.
So to do animation, you
want to name the animation
on the element that
you'd like to animate.
So this is going to be the
fade-in animation And then
in our component
definition, we can
set the animation's metadata.
And so we want to trigger
an animation called fade-in.
And we want it to
transition when it enters.
We want it to start with a--
oops, that's not what I want--
a style of opacity zero.
We want it to animate
for 750 milliseconds
with an ease-out curve.
And this did not come
in, so let's get that in.
And then we want it to
start or to end on a state
where the style is opacity one.
So that was very quick.
So let's hope that worked.
So it's loading.
There we go, so you can
see the dogs fade in.
So we have our Material
Design components.
We have some forms.
We have some animations.
Hopefully that gives you
kind of a sense of what it's
like to develop in Angular.
So that's it for the live demo.
Thank you for watching.
SPEAKER 3: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
SPEAKER 1: And that
was the introduction
to what's been new in Angular.
[CHINESE]
SPEAKER 4: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]